[Music]
all right in that's one way to do it
news
this is submitted by JK in fancies 2016
let's work on that name next time a
teacher sparked controversy for making
students wear cardboard boxes on their
heads listen I'm gonna be honest with
you guys I was a substitute teacher in
schools I did seven grade science for
three years and I did jail I've seen a
lot of ugly people how would make
somebody wait no I think you're calling
them ugly though mm-hmm no I'm not what
he's doing is he's protecting the kids
from being bully right cuz I'm not the
bullies don't have to see their face but
only inside that box I definitely write
you ugly
for people with walleyes it's necessary
what ice wall ice what is that when you
do have eyes where you can't get away
from because your picture frame like the
Mona Lisa looks like you're constantly
staring at me which is a [ __ ] croc is
like [ __ ] one foot long it's like a
big baseball card I thought I was gonna
be huge they do like a dictators
portrait or so aren't you glad that you
got to take a picture of it with your
phone so that you can join tens of
thousands other people ton of people
there I was like for what that's it my
mom with me that's just my when it got a
wheelchair for her legs hurting so you
can get closer with the wheelchair and I
took this bar
she was right by but I didn't even get
her I was like I thought they were way
better they were huge it was like the
whole [ __ ] fruits and [ __ ] not famous
sorry that's the Kardashian the first
Kardashian was Mona Lisa hot shoes the
first [ __ ] selfie huh not that good
but but it's known for being famous and
so everyone has to see it that's Dan
that's deep bro and I actually don't
think Kim Kardashian is great but all
right this teacher here in Mexico it has
been has been accused of humiliating and
breaking the basic human rights of his
students after he forced his students to
wear cardboard boxes in order to prevent
them from cheating on a test oh it was
because they were ugly that is hilarious
though how did he say that many boxes
and if everybody like of all his cat
classes accuser to say boxes those boxes
reek of breath
well he's drinking a lot cuz a lot of
them are beer boxes dude this guy's
driving you all truck to school with no
boxes like these little [ __ ] aren't
cheating today man no way you can't
bring our big got big mess if Steve's
[ __ ] no cuz I would write all the
answers on the inside of the box then
and now it's still cheap but I could
just turn the box around and have all
these that's funny
this guy's too crafty for that [ __ ] you
got out yeah I think outside the box oh
I would never say something like that
I was terrible yeah wittiest no that was
an accident
look at the box look at those those
boxers though they look like [ __ ]
wall-e with the two eyes and also he cut
out the hands that I could still see
just get them blinders that's a lot of
boxes to bring a class that's so funny
dude yeah I love it that is great
yeah I think it's easier to chew at the
box it is not a cub right you could
cover your side I there's no light in
there bro you can't see [ __ ] but you
could see you can see a friend over
there I don't think this guy ever
cheated in his life then yeah yeah
once you've cheated on a test you know
the [ __ ] angles you know like the
body move and you know what's your light
source hotshot a hotshot were some
[ __ ] thing this thing smoking for me
there's light everywhere in there yeah I
mean it's not it's not a [ __ ] black
like a darkroom film you want to do
eight holes of golf after this is that a
white person thing does they do do white
people [ __ ] I'm like hey let's gentrify
this neighborhood is that somewhere
people [ __ ] yes absolutely
are we surprised now
that does live it at least I can see
someone call me a hotshot
you're the first hotshot thanks
only Steve are your former PE teacher ah
no even repeat it you have Mexican pee
teachers yeah
where does your light source no hot shot
you put yourself on an airy party so the
lights go getting in that's units a
division the front was cut out yeah
their whole bodies not it's the whole
[ __ ] hotshot hotshot oh that's the wait
I thought there was no is so I'm all the
way over here you're right up close to
it those look like logos to me not faces
oh okay well look closely you said this
guy drinks a lot you didn't look close
enough to see me I have terrible vision
I came back on the [ __ ] land Steve I
will win you'll see some of them help
some of them have sunroofs some of them
you see that [ __ ] oh yeah that's nice
yeah they cut the top that's the life
force that's the legend a man was able
to explain what gee oh man you couldn't
back up what he said you couldn't beat
him so you had to go for someone yeah
yeah yeah no you never weaker well no he
answered your question in his head he
thinks I'm weak oh I was just looking
for an answer to your question and he
provided it not you he's right about
that
hey all right you you are I was right
which always in but definitely this here
there this is about you guys I'm always
right well he's not my friend anymore so
all right hotshot
that's fine hotshot anyway so I want to
be a hotshot
[Music]
[Laughter]
because you wipe the wrong way white you
criminal you this Eddie stands up but
you pointed out everyone he wipes any
smears in his back that's not true first
of all I don't white I just get in the
shower and clean that's the only way you
can use your hand to wipe I don't hide
it I get in spread the cheese's let the
water do what it does that's disgusting
I don't have a bidet I don't have a
bidet what happened up man that's what I
print no I can't afford me examines I
get an upgrade that means I got to take
you with me all I got to keep the old
toilet to put it back when I leave oh I
see I'm not giving him [ __ ] when I leave
you got stank ass but I want to hear
about these kids all right
I've been here pocket as I hate that's
usually my role in the group yes okay so
a parent like one of the parents they
post it on Facebook to sport this photo
saying that they will denounce these
acts of humiliation physical emotional
and psychological violence oh man
where is this this is a Mexico that's so
funny because there's like real violence
there and this is what they're worried
about
that's what I was thinking when I was
reading this I'm like come on guy and in
Mexico those boxes are people's homes
when what what yeah sometimes in T one
that's 13 down thumbs right there no but
think of it cuz you're just saying you
don't want these people to take your
[ __ ] with you right when you die what
about if you look at a [ __ ] box
you're you want listen yeah we would not
be using carb I mean I've seen a house
literally it's a one box one to buy for
some tarp and then that wavy steel thing
that turned into a house that's that's
tight I never would just live like
danceBlue but I know exactly what you're
talking about I'm talking about oh that
was completely different but I know what
you're talking about
that was there's a little different of
how years later that curly still thing
that you know was amazing pairs of such
[ __ ] nowadays excusing legs but that
is that's that's the weakest thing to
really make a complaint I agree but I
thought I thought it was hilarious
my daughter told me she just she just
said when tonight grade this is that
they had all the the Grace and
difference Weiss and they started the
senior high chair dingy got through the
freshman's and all the other classes
she's like I cried I thought you cried
like yeah it was sad they were bullying
us like [ __ ] you you don't deserve clap
you just got here we don't know what
you're gonna [ __ ] do but you do she
was like well I'm getting in sophomore
I'm not gonna do that you're [ __ ]
liar you absolutely are that's what
every freshman says they'll become a
slowly you gotta do what your friends
are gonna do think you proved that with
your grace last year so I don't tell me
you free because it's fun to hate the
freshmen that was fun nice take like
this coming from middle school yeah
people are more [ __ ] now they're way
more [ __ ] and I like how you use that
as a sign of weakness cuz I agree
[ __ ] are we mmm no no I didn't mean
like that no
[Laughter]
I point to make him Jamaican say [ __ ]
boy all the time we don't have to be
girls I know you're saying nope you
don't I was back with lemon
women are the toughest creatures on the
planet
oh yeah me too hey me too but me too we
do on a daily basis but yeah now women
listen you know what nothing's stronger
than to Pechanga they don't have a lot
of give to that's what we're saying I
think I think we should petition the
straws to have anime fighter come into
every single class while they're
studying and just beat the [ __ ] out of
people randomly I think that would be
awesome like they need to I don't know
man like there's not enough stress right
yeah we got to just create stress in a
safe environment of course see we're
coming up we play a lot of games that
made us tough like I was coming up we
used to play this gang called BB bushes
but I say if you say anything with a B
word we would punch you in - you said BB
bushes so you've living playing video
games like [ __ ] I bit block about
four six different people a baby bushes
right well it's like slug bugs whatever
right well slide bug is only when you
see the slug I mean I see the bug phone
yeah so we plan BB bushes we're playing
left hand give it up so you have
anything edible or drinkable your left
hand I see us a left hand give it up you
have to give me that and I can drink it
I can give back to throw it away I can
like I played with my tour guys what's
up and I'd like to smash their pieces
throw it across the room whatever yeah
so we plan that then give it up BB
bushes open chest and open nuts so now
you're walking around like this the
whole time
good fight training all right already
right cuz you want to roll off the
shoulder right and then you stand where
you got your left hand cuz we can't use
that right made a sub though I like that
do they participate in this game I think
so you're like well let's play left hand
run it all at the same time so then
they're like you're like okay let's all
agree we're playing the left hand thing
so whatever is amount of 10 you can take
or punch right so they're like okay and
like oh you know what I want a slice of
pizza and then they grab all two left
hand like that like that quick you
forget because you've got so much we're
playing for gays left hand give it up BB
bushes open chest and open nuts right
and so you forget that cuz like if we're
if we're not around each other you're
not gonna we say like that but if I
sneak and come up to your house and I
see you just up there like stray
[ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] your chest up oh
this one you play now I'm a punch on
your chest some more cuz you just said
[ __ ] you just like it's just like a
blunt - oh man it sucked all day but it
made me cognizant made me stronger so
made you alert make me alert paranoid of
the world there you go
I don't trust anybody you don't see any
of yours either
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]